they we're looking at the me know how
many of you Greta philosophical dialogue
whether it's Plato or anybody else
before so maybe a fifth of the class so
this is a new thing for you yeah we're
going to be reading a lot of other
dialogues this the semester
this class is oriented around dialogue
and dialectic two different terms that
are that are connected with each other a
dialogue is sort of like a play except
it's not so much a play in which people
fall in love or kill each other or you
know sorts of things that you're used to
maybe in plays you studied in high
school or or here in another classes
this dialogue is focused on a particular
topic so if you had to sum it up in one
word what's the one worthy see coming up
over and over collision well that's so
that's a topic that comes up along the
way and some people think that's the
most important thing about this dialogue
but what is the explicit focus okay yeah
this weird version and we're going to do
a little bit of unpacking and
examination of what is that because is
that a term that you use all the time do
bring up somebody that you like is being
virtuous over in the cafeteria that's
guys virtuous one hang on the count no I
mean you could but it's not part of our
culture anymore is it people did 100
years ago ah very virtuous girl I didn't
recommend you spend time with her now we
don't talk like that right so we have to
do a little bit of exploration what was
this again mean not just what does it
mean in plate up what would it mean for
you guys and before we do that though
who are the people that are that are
actually involved yeah no help
yeah named after this guy me know metal
and then Greek mainland actually who
else here's the main character
yeah here's another one you can see him
show up over and over again
now there's two minor characters to
bit-part supporting roles you can call
yeah yeah servant or slave the grease
and the institution of slavery very
different than the Antebellum American
slavery they had a lot of possible
servants often not treated very well may
not treat his guy then who else there's
one other guy shows up yeah
I'm not going to get upset if you
mispronounce these things as a matter of
fact almost all of our English
pronunciations are mispronunciations in
the Greek that Socrates it's so practice
you know but we don't have to be
sticklers about that sort of stuff so
long as we understand it so long as it
starts with an hey I'm fine with that
so Meena what do we know about this guy
is it first off is he from Athens
Socrates is from animals is Meno from
animals he's from somewhere else right
yeah very good and thusly is to the
north of Athens it was kind of a rougher
more more rural country area and if you
had to say something about where like me
no fit in with Society did you get any
sense about that like Indian you know we
think about a class system where didn't
even fit in
Oh probably upper level because he had
hired to be a Bhaskar
servants make this journey yeah very
good
he'd only have servants there he
actually brings something we'll get them
to another city right now he he's not a
philosopher per se he's very interested
in Socrates who has a reputation for
being a philosopher and Meno talks about
studying with a couple of people over
the courses people that they get company
called Sophists and a lot get mix mix
those up so this guy Gor dias
Leon Tita my thing who Socrates also
knows a lot of these people know each
other these dialogues me know his
friends with Socrates and he's also
friends with a dentist's as manufactured
families have been friends for a long
time this is something very important
for upper upper middle class Greeks -
they have these long-standing family
friendship for generation after
generation after generation so these
guys are connected with each other this
guy works for from you know so Socrates
is the only one who was kind of the odd
man out of this what can you tell me
about soccer what did you glean from
from this guy a lot what would you say
about him just just right now you don't
got to be the most profound things in
the world is your gonna study of a lot
more he's often questioning a lot of
things that people say or that he says
he's very good yeah that's that's
integral to his approach to things he
has a lot of questions and so some of
they asked us at the beginning of class
about Socratic method when people talk
about the Socratic method generally what
they mean is a type of education which
you can ask the students questions
trying to elicit responses from them and
you don't like give them a doctrine so
here's what to learn here's the study
guide you try to you know get them to
think about stuff it's kind of
open-ended that's what Socrates does yes
miss Carroll open-minded and
but I think like outside of the box but
it seems that like he's very like humble
about like yeah like that yeah very good
he there's a big challenge in Hindman
Anytus answers a young upper-class guy
thinks that he knows it all that's why I
get so angry because Socrates is not
actually it's not easier than even
attacking him he's attacking people that
the Anytus thinks are you know top now
sort of like that if you complain about
somebody else's football team or a band
that they like or you know the political
candidate that therefore they get all
worked up that's what happens in the
anapest your idea Socrates is very hot
he doesn't doesn't make a lot of himself
he doesn't claim that he actually knows
things that he doesn't know he wants to
measure whether he does don't face me
know and and Anytus are perfectly
willing to come on and say I know what
this is then when you push them it turns
out they don't actually know quite so
much this is the slave the servant he
doesn't pretend that he knows anything
because of course he's you know who's
lower down in the total turns out he
actually does know some interesting
facts so these are our four voices and
to make sense out of a platonic dialogue
you want to you want to be able to
distinguish them from each other and
sometimes not so much in this dialogue
but in some other dialogues the very way
in which they talk is conveying
something about the position that they
hold and it is to a certain extent the
artist gets gets upset very quickly
doesn't mean I was kind of a nice genial
everybody that ought to get along kind
of guy
Socrates really does provoke people he
is humble like you're saying but he also
doesn't let up people
that can be a bit disconcerting well
that's good
now the dialogue is supposed to be about
virtue it starts out of the question
convert should be taught an [ __ ] what
is virtue is it just about that or if we
add the doctrine of recollection the
does that exhaust with this dialogue is
about something good to think about are
there any of the things you'd say the
dialogue any other topics you to the
dialogue touched on it was about yeah
talk about like human perception
perception yeah me like sense perception
um the whole thing where he was
comparing the figures and the colors
where yeah it's mostly we only compare
were solely because something ends yeah
okay he actually brings up this guy and
pedak lee is very briefly it doesn't
tell you much about pedigrees was
another philosopher previous to Socrates
anything else that came up maybe you'll
see it as we as we go through it this is
one of the things about the tonic
dialogue there's always a lot more going
on than you caught the first time around
on the second time around I've been
reading this since I was your age and
when I first read it I thought it was
very boring as matter of fact as a new
boring for at least a good ten years
because I thought was basically about
the doctrine recollection and once
you've got that down Plato thinks that
when we learn things you know we're
actually being there being recalled to
us because we saw them previously in
life before this life all right I got
that down why
with all this blathering about virtue at
that time I was very uninterested in
virtue
- I think partners nobody made the
connection for me there's just an
old-fashioned fusty sound word and that
is I read morkul Tomic dialogues this
one came to seem kind of small in
comparison because there's you know the
Republic and symposia and all these
other great dialogues like the Phaedo
you're going to read next week and those
seemed a lot more interest a lot more
was going on and then as I started to
have to teach this I started realizing
just how much stuff was going on in here
and then so it took me you know 10 years
to actually start figuring out what was
in here and every time that I teach it I
come across one or two other things that
I missed in this very short dialogue
well that's the sign of a piece of
classic literature you know think about
the movies that you like to watch over
and over again do you like to watch it
over and over again because every time
you watch it it's exactly the same thing
you're just so comforted by you know
having identity over and over again in
your life or do you watch movies over
and over again the ones that you do
because each time you watch it you're
like oh man I miss that that changes the
whole plot there that little detail the
other movies you get bored with don't
you well it's the same way with a
platonic dialogue so if you if you don't
get everything that's going on with the
first time that's to be expected that's
why we have these class sessions to try
to open up some of these things so
before we actually look at some of what
we're gonna pop these two days
something about Socrates and his method
what we can say about this so you're
right he is what does that mean to be to
be home we generally see it as a good
thing right if we use that term what
does that mean what do you think to
realize that there's a lot of days to
know and find out after the world and
have all the answers that you're willing
to learn
all right that's very good realizes
there's lots o the way to learn or is
yeah you know if people are unwilling to
learn it so oftentimes they think they
already know it and then you can't
debate it they already know if they want
to listen to you right think about when
you're having that most feared out of
the position of actually teaching people
at this point some of you will be later
on but think about when you're trying to
inform a friend about some thing that
happened and they think they know all
about it and they don't need to hear
you're sore if your story or the details
that you have because they already know
all the facts that would be the opposite
is right what else can we see about here
somebody said they asked questions on so
this is an interesting thing when
Socrates is asking questions there's
different ways you can ask questions
what what are rhetorical questions
I'm not asking rhetorical question and
asking that yeah like questions that
they're just us but without really
demanding
yeah you're not demanding an answer
because you feel like everybody should
know the answer right
you're not thief after all you shouldn't
have to say yes I'm not a thief dr.
Sandler I'm informing you I don't steal
things it's supposed to be a citizen
sort of like a remark that that is
framed like a question but is really the
statement it's not producing gauging in
any rhetorical questions here I think if
you dig around and find some of those
questions are like that he's actually
making statements by asking questions
some of his questions are genuine like
what do you think about this I don't
know you think tell me what you think
yeah the one of the rhetorical stainless
be when he's talking about how you can't
define virtue by itself he'll weaken the
pieces yeah although I did a lot of
cases he's willing to make statements
about that he criticizes me nonsense I
screwing around with me you know I'm
asking you from this whole thing here
and you give me this little bit here and
then say yeah it's all like that it's
all pretty much like like this so some
of that's statements some of that's
questions I suppose of complaints of the
attach statement you're not giving me
what I want different kinds of what we
call speech hands notice another thing
about the way you ask questions when
Socrates ask somebody a question they'll
say well what do you think about this
how does this strike it and then they'll
say well here's what I think or you'll
say do you know what X is I'll say yeah
here's what it is do they stop there
yeah
he doesn't say oh great thanks see you
later
I'm all done here he says oh yeah that's
that's really interesting is this the
right answer if you really know what
you're talking about
well of course let's play around with it
see how it pans out that's what Socrates
does so this is something very important
not just for Socrates not just for Plato
but for philosophy and also for your
lives in general you don't want to just
ask people questions get the answers and
then move on if you want to actually
know something if you want to be secure
about things you want to know why people
say I'm think of the things that they do
whether what they're saying is actually
correct or not whether they can back it
up whether their account can can hold up
how else decide you ask questions you
make some statements he doesn't let up
on people what else have you noticed
about the way in which he goes about
things yeah then figure out like a
little bit on their own it's a
revelation to them yeah that's going to
fit in with this doctrine of
recollection - that's very important
does use a lot of examples or a lot of
analogies yeah it was always related to
people that Nina would know or me a
saying regarding of people that's
interesting that's not something that I
had actually thought about and then put
into to my notes but you're right and he
and Socrates Plato does this Plato's
young speaking through Socrates does
this throughout the dialogues he'll
always try to put in terms of what
somebody already has to start something
familiar with them I think that's why
using examples that does
uses examples that they can relate to
this is actually one of the obstacles in
reading the context could you relate to
all the examples that he gets in here
how many of you live in agricultural
life Brooke on a farm anybody sort of
yeah me me me to sort of you know not
fully but I had a lot of friends at
farms you know a lot of those metaphors
make a lot more sense when you've
actually got some experiential
background he's going to talk about
cobblers how many of us have cobble
shoes not too many
as a matter of fact my wife was just
telling me she's finally found a cobbler
in Kingston so I can get a pair of dress
shoes that I've got that the sole wore
out of other souls and there's a hole in
the soul it's that hard to find somebody
who can actually do that because we live
in this machine production age right
back in their time that you know this is
a common thing if you want to choose
somebody had to make those shoes for you
and that guy was called cobbler so he's
going to talk about a lot of examples
and really hard for you to relate to
some of the examples here's oh audience
would have been very familiar with this
so sometimes we have to do a little bit
of work with them there's one other
thing I want to bring out the bus
Socrates and this comes a little bit
later on in the dialogue me know he has
a complaint that he makes about Socrates
after Minos tried out a couple different
definitions of virtue what is that
complaint once was he complaining
Meno starts out he says yeah I can talk
in front of large crowds about first
year I've done a whole bunch of times
people say I know what I'm talking about
yeah did he say that on he made that
Socrates made me no question everything
that he thought he believed that it was
almost like he cast a spell on him
yeah yeah actually like it paralyzed him
the term that they use in your
translation is torpedo other others
translators a stingray in the
Mediterranean I guess there's a kind of
Ray that when it when it hits things it
paralyzes them it stuns them it messes
them up think about an electric eel
maybe not usually that kills things but
you know think about when you get zapped
right now what happens give us in a
platonic dialogue is it kind of stunning
confusion now is that a good thing or a
bad thing it kind of depends doesn't it
if you're just going around and trying
to screw with people and destroy the
worldviews and tear them down
and you're not actually offering of
anything in return maybe that's not a
good thing maybe you're just being a
jerk it's a lot of people plus Socrates
is do it if you're going to go out and
do that today people would still call
you a jerk wouldn't they
there are jerks out there who do that
Socrates doesn't want matically like say
okay now that I clear the path for you
here's the right way of thinking either
doesn't which may be a little bit
unsatisfying
a lot of people find the Platonic guy
unsatisfying because they're like cheese
just gets the point just tell me what it
is I'm supposed to know or think so I
can actually be done with it but Plato
thinks that this is actually part of the
process of learning if you're already
convinced that you know something it
takes being shaken a bit to realize no
actually I'm not that smart that that
humility doesn't come without being
humbled and the way that you're humbled
is somebody comes along shows that
you're not as good as you think or
you're not as smart as you think doesn't
mean that you couldn't be it just means
that at that point in time you're not
and a lot of Education works this way
that's again what Socratic questioning
is supposed to do it's supposed to
introduce complexity into its it's a so
another area just don't take everything
at face value yeah that could be one way
one way to put it I mean there could be
some things that you can't it you could
be sure about later on right but you
can't be sure about anything until you
really test them you're gonna say
something yeah there's just actually had
a question regards to Socrates ideas in
this link could he purposely try to
confuse people because of his mind if
you one idea if it is a statement or
anything like that should never be
confused should apply to home account
oh that's getting us towards definition
so that's actually a good segue and to
what's going on so let's move into into
this
they start out talking about version
right you having Socrates and Meena are
contrasting each other Meno says and we
all do this and so actually says yeah it
should we don't as a matter of fact if
you go to any Athenian guide you say
what's rich you'll say I don't have
somebody else now this is kind of an
important thing because virtue means
something Browdy excellence goodness
comes from the word re stems from which
we get aristocracy ruled by the the best
on each dose is the best on art a virtue
means something like moral goodness or
some kind of excellence so if you're
really bright you have a good memory
that's a virtue if you're a just person
you're fair you can be relied upon
you're what we call a stand-up guy
that's a that's a version being
courageous you know for the Greeks being
courageous actually meant fewer like you
know among the upper class or middle
class that when the city called you on
war you grab your shield and this you
know rather flimsy armor and a spear and
sword and you went out stood with a
whole bunch of other guys you having at
each other trying to run each other
through a Spears I took a lot of courage
to actually like not break and say screw
this I'm getting out of here these are
things that people looked up to it could
also be in terms of like speaking
ability in terms of artistic production
you know as a matter of fact the Greeks
applied this to sort of all across the
board so anything that you are good at
could be a virtue you're good at
knitting scarves that might be a virtue
yeah that's actually where Minos can
stir it out because Minos being asked
what's the definition of virtue if you
know what virtue is tell me what it is
this gets to the
issue you know the many and the one
nothing happy with them
before that though let's think about
virtue in our own time so we have a
little bit more to connect this with so
if I put in terms of this like
excellence or moral goodness what sort
of qualities do you look up to in person
what do you praise that's another way of
figuring out what what is it Richard
yeah doing anything okay so when it's
working noise about making noise fibers
okay yeah that's there's a difference
between doing the right thing because
everybody's looking at you and doing the
right thing let's say even except for
yourself right or maybe even when it
goes against your own interests yeah
okay what would you put with some of
that this would be like one of those
what else would be comprised under any
of it like a whole tool what else would
be put in there
okay very good
that's a trait that a lot of people
admire right that might actually be can
align with this to telling the truth
even when you don't have to even when
nobody's going to call you even when
maybe actually it reveals you at a less
than perfect light that you'd rather be
in you know that's a moral value I think
that's a pretty laudable
I think most of you probably it's kind
of a gut instinct about that right
that's a good thing any other things
that you would say let's get one more
guy to say like good a common name
helping a stranger neighbor okay
eating circle big old name now here's an
interesting way to think about this
dialogue is in part about can what it
what is virtue what is moral goodness is
there anything that actually connects
all of these together or connects the
things of Plato's talking about then
there's the question can it be taught
and that's something worth thinking
about people that have these qualities
and there are a lot of people who have
these qualities and there's a lot of
people who lack these qualities to write
in our society how did they get them did
they get them because somebody taught
them to be that way did they get them to
sort of that random you know sort of
left there's a pack of cards and some
people get the good cards and some
people people do the bad cards did you
know some sort of God or divinity sort
of push it into our skulls and some
again some people got got the good draw
some people got the bad draw these are
these are questions that you really
ought to think about particularly few of
some sort of interest in seeing people
people how do we actually make people
into good people if it can meet a lot
who can teach these things can just
anybody teach these or because we
require some sort of special training
it's kind of funny some of you are you
know in your lifetime and have to go to
lots and lots of sessions where you're
like learning about moral values and how
to behave in the workplace all necessary
well some of you were the millers he
already had to do a lot of those and you
look at some of these people that
they're teaching and you're like man
this is really in Congress this person
shouldn't be teaching this kind of stuff
because they're a complete you know
opposite to what they're supposed to be
teaching there's there's there's other
cases like this too I go to a lot of
seminars where there are teachers like
teaching teachers about how to teach
well and the seminar itself which is
horrible
you'll be like man this person can't
teach to save their life I don't know
how they got to become an expert why are
we paying them so that's a real vital
question when it comes to you know
either teaching or oral life even just
on the job stuff and I think less or
take morality is I just think about
excellence in your workplace excellence
in your field how do people actually
learn these things who can actually
teach them so we're going to talk more
about that next time I just want to sort
of plant that seed in your head now
we'll talk about this is questionable
what is the first you can we define
if you know virtue as being this you
could probably give me some on-the-spot
definition of it and I'd be willing to
bet that in a lot of cases it would look
a lot like what Maino did the first
couple tries what does his first try
actually he doesn't actually like list
off bunch of qualities doesn't say it's
justice temperance courage or anything
like that and you might do after taking
that expose what does he say he says
here's the one who is virtually goals
mole requires so what do you mean by
role here well you know different people
are different roles different you know
your students not for instance I'm a
professor do we have certain duties or
obligations to each other there's
certain things that you know make you a
good student or a bad students or things
that make me a good professor a bad
professor yeah and there's some things
that are probably neither here nor there
as a matter if I wear a jacket and tie
for the quality of your education is
there any point to my wearing a jacket
in time maybe a little but it's pretty
what we call ancillary to the purpose of
Education what should I be doing should
I like to show off the last minute we're
going to do say I just want to open
what do you think about them you know
how does it make you feel wait for you
to say so and say it's really really
good
everybody gets a gold star that being a
good professor have you having any
teachers like that you learn anything in
their classes I never did it was
incredibly frustrating for me to begin
people like that and I imagine is this
for some of you the what will be the
opposite extreme okay I'm the professor
you're the student I talk you listen
here's what's going on in the Meno
somebody raise their hand put your hand
down
we don't do that sort of thing here I
would not be fulfilling my role very
well what so me knows idea is well
everybody's got these roles and virtue
is something that's like you know
appropriate to each role so there'd be a
certain way of being a good professor
maybe more than one
what about being a good student what
should a good student how should they
behave
we do that yeah according to your
syllabus well I mean maybe that's what
they'll have a good teacher I mean if
I'm a bad professor my syllabus is
probably a mess you know what's
something you'd bring if you're a good
teacher or a good student we bring it to
every class what are you a good
professor yeah
your attention hmm that's one important
thing right there is if you actually pay
attention that's like half the battle
already I've taught in places where like
most the students are not paying
attention because there's a bad student
culture and they just sort of think bill
kind of like absorb it at the last
minute now you guys know it doesn't work
right that's not gonna make you
successful if I go like do they come
prepared to class yeah that's a big
thing too you know read read the thing
at least you know once or twice before
coming to class it's like a minimal
level yeah showing respect yeah I just
taught in places where people called me
peach you know they get my name wrong at
the end of the semester you know
probably yeah
keeping the discussion relevant other
than that I think I saw this guy walking
across the street yesterday we have to
do what we're talking about that's
that's what else will towards your
fellow students right yeah have to come
in willing to actually learn yeah that's
that's a big part of it too
and so now we have all sorts of things
that we can say as examples of what the
goal of student requires and Meno says
is for a little bunch of other studies
and manly virtue and he's making like
upper class aristocratic virtue but the
virtue of a man consists in managing the
city's affair capably so that he will
help his friends and injure his foes
while taking care to come to and will
harm himself that's kind of an
interesting way to look at it he'll be a
successful politician
help his friends hurt his enemies make
sure he doesn't get hurt make sure the
city doesn't close down a woman's virtue
that's easily described she must be the
housewife careful with her stores
obedient to her husband the very you
know traditional understanding the
Athenians by the way we're one of the
most sex segregated
sighs women were almost always just
confined in the household not all the
other Greeks did that there's another
virtue for a child another for an old
man a great many other kinds of virtue
so he says nobody has to you know think
too much about this you just look at
what the role is and then see how how
you do it well so garbage man is a
certain kind of virtue the president of
the college would have another kind of
virtue be a whole bunch of different
kinds of virtues and Socrates is not
very happy with this and why not
most doesn't tell you anything but what
virtue is this just tells you about what
in each case virtue and count for and
Socrates says I want a definition this
isn't a definition this is just a whole
bunch of examples what should a
definition do when you go to the
dictionary because you don't understand
a term you don't want that just to say
well it's kind of like this and kind of
like that maybe you know if you look at
this over here that's kind of what I'm
talking about
right you wouldn't keep that dictionary
would you what do you want in a
definition yeah something Barney style
breaks down makes it understandable for
the general population okay so when it
breaks it down yeah what a little
different the tea very good yeah
definition all the examples of something
that definition has to apply all it has
to describe something that they all have
in common so if you're going to define
go on you know instead of just like
pointing at a chihuahua and a Great Dane
and saying it's like you know this and
that and everything else in between you
got to say well what are these actually
have in common with each other because
you know some of them somebody brings in
achievements this is a door
no that's a sheep well why well because
you know you start going down the list
of things you know well the Sheep
doesn't handle those same things and it
doesn't eat meat as far as we know and
didn't evolve in this certain way you
can give all sorts of definitions all
sorts of essential features a definition
picks out when you call the essence what
it is a thing so Socrates says that's
what I want from this don't tell me that
an old man is one kind of virtue in a
you know the child is another kind of
virtue and somebody in charge of the
city has another keverage you tell me
what they all have in common and Meno
says I don't really understand what
you're saying and Socrates has to go
through some some examples and and try
to make it clear for him
yeah Socrates says well here's a
suggestion for you could it be like this
so I noticed this is asking a question
but it's kind of a leading question
isn't it he wants me to say yes to this
let me know can make the conversation
Percy since is there anything that they
do have in common could it be that they
direct things well whatever it is that
their role is they're doing it doing
what your role requires okay Wow what
does that mean what is it to do to
fulfill your role well Socrates suggests
maybe that means being just and
temperate for moderate being just means
being fair following the rules doing you
know what you ought to do being
temperate or moderate means keeping
things within certain limits basically
keeping your appetites your desire to
fit certain limits so you know think
about people's appetites for for food or
for sacks or for watching TV or anything
that we enjoy right could those things
get in the way of you fulfilling
let's take just thing about student life
what could get in the way of you
fulfilling your roles in student to the
say come to class prepared
yeah drinking it's fun drink that's why
people do it right it's enjoyable and
after you have you know done it then you
might actually desire it and it might be
for a variety of reasons you might
actually like the taste of it at first
that's not the case right you just sort
of get get through it so that you can
get something else what is this
something else you want
you have a feeling of the high that
comes with the box but after a while you
come to like certain things you know a
friend of mine turned me on in the last
couple years to good scotch I had a
vicodin scotch because 24 bad scotch is
worth drinking and but you know you keep
and when you drink it you drink just a
little bit because you save not drinking
it to get drunk you're tasting the
flavors in it that's intensely enjoyable
I can see why people get into that I can
remind people show out sometimes 300
bucks a bottle for this stuff there's a
300 bucks but you're not going up
pouring yourself shots of it you know
Thursday night but if you don't roll
together all these are going to enjoy
about drinking if you indulge yourself
and that as much as you want you're not
going to be a good student it will be
over there on the other side of the
street right or you know up at Darb you
not that much Derby's or or ever down in
for Kip see what else what else would
get anyway that that's probably the
biggest one right that are inserted
drawn secure get yourself addicted to
heroin
your student life is over that's totally
thing compatible
there are some smaller things up so
smaller designers they like to keep it
changing sleep that's a big one for
students students are mostly sleep
deprived because you have so many
interesting things going on it's usually
because you've been indulging yourself
in some other desire to write like
watching TV but video games hang out
friends going out all those sorts of
things then at the end of the semester
it's because you're getting caught up on
everything cramming so you know in order
to fulfill your role well you would have
to be like it says moderate or tempura
but here's a problem moderation and
justice are types of virtue so what does
that mean
that means that in trying to get what
the essence of the virtue is you'd be
taking a part of it and saying well so
long as you do what it is that you're
doing with this part of virtue what you
do is virtuous it's part of the whole
that isn't it seem a little circular to
you when you put it like that at first
it sounded pretty good didn't it then
when you examine it now it starts to
seem a little circular that's because it
is circular it's not actually helping
you to define virtue you know if justice
is a virtue and we're trying to figure
out what virtue is it doesn't help you
to say well it's anything you do with
justice right that's not actually get it
giving you understanding of what it is
to be a virtue
so Meno tries another thing makes
another attempt any no me no is really
trying hard you notice he's not getting
angry with Socrates
people know he's not getting frustrated
it's only after three tries to be says
man Socrates what they say about you is
actually true you confuse people and you
know they have no idea when we what
they're doing after some time Mema says
maybe virtue is the capacity to rule or
government people you know it makes
sense
NATO's from the upper class they do a
lot of ruling in governing even in its
own household is to tell people what to
do maybe that's virtuous and then
Socrates as well there's there's two
problems one is could a child have
virtue then the children get to tell
people what to do in a well-run
household forget like the terror kids
here you know see them at the
supermarket you're like man there's
something disciplined that kid you've
all said that and we will till the end
of time because there's going to be some
people are good parents and some people
are bad parents could this fit for
children
no what about for like at the sermon guy
he's got is that's irreverent ruling
anybody there is a server venoth so that
that's a problem right there but there's
a deeper problem again ruling or
governing people how many of you via
jobs that you didn't particularly like
so all of you some jobs
what would you don't like about the job
yeah it's too many unions and
opportunities not enough Indians too
many people telling you what to do okay
yeah like that and then there you get
conflicting orders that that's a problem
yeah micromanaging okay yeah that that's
sort of even if you just have one person
if they're always like second guessing
yeah the boss okay yeah yeah that makes
it very adult oh you worked in a factory
or a restaurant sure sounds tough yeah
that makes a doll somebody else have any
other that's missing being the boss some
kind of sense yeah I can tell you I was
happier as a student than an awful lot
more as your professor so the boss you
have good bosses and you had bad losses
right sounds like you have the Deaf boss
you had too many bosses ruling or
governing isn't enough to make a virtue
again we have this doing it well what
does that mean again well doing it just
lis doing it fairly if somebody stock up
there's a certain unfairness in the way
that they approach you right they treat
themselves as if they're better than
year without having good cause to do so
it could be that somebody actually is
better than you and then you might not
feel so bad if they don't you know
interact with you as much right but if
they if they're on the same level as you
and they act like they're not that
that's kind of kind of sticks in your
craw doesn't it that's being unjust in
plato's terms
so again governing people well what is
well mean justly now we've got we're
back at the same place again our way
Socrates says I wanted the whole of
virtue and again you're telling me about
a bit of it and that's nice but that
isn't what I asked you about so he asks
them about another one and this is the
most interesting we're not actually
going to explore this
today because it raises some other
issues some other very interesting
issues so it's hem 2 3 has to do with
saying that virtue is desired good
things and good in a certain set good
noble fine things and being able to get
them now this has to do with no longer
what you do so much more with what you
wanted what you have and this can make
sense if you think about people that you
consider to be good people you would say
that their desires are good right that's
murder what makes them good you know if
somebody actually has a desire to hurt
you for no reason what you call them a
good person what do you call them as a
bad person we have certain other words
like psycho is you know yeah the
Psychopaths or sociopaths are you
usually it's not so much that they just
want to hurt people that's more sadist
but sociopaths lack a sense of
conscience so if you get in their way
they'll do anything to get you out of it
and there are no restraints of it and
then it's to do with their desires you
know if you have been involved in a
friendship or a relationship with
somebody and you can after a while kind
of tell you can't like look into
somebody's head oh there's that desire
you can kind of get a sense of what it
is that makes them tick what they're
after sometimes they actually tell you
like this and you're like oh that's
that's kind of gross
you're you're kind of kind of disgusting
I want to be with you anymore
they give you a really I never have
anybody like you know sets the hairs on
the back your neck up a person gives me
the shivers are kind of creepy
that's about having bad desires they
haven't actually done anything for
you're like man I don't want to walk
down the dark alley with that guy for
that girl
this one knows what they're into
actually I know what you're going to do
I don't like it the opposite that would
be good desires having desires for good
things and we could you know go through
a whole range of those yeah so couldn't
the very idea of good desires he
completely perfected like to some degree
yeah and that's actually where we're
going to go with this we're going to
talk more about that next class the
problem is people do in fact desire bad
things we know right some people desire
bad things some people actually do go
out and get bad things do they always
realize that they're bad things
sometimes they actually think that
they're good things and then you know
for instance of one month's like the the
drug addict who becomes hopelessly
addicted to one of the really hard drugs
like methamphetamine or crack okay PCP
heroin you know any of the ones that
will totally ruin your life that make it
impossible to do anything else
they don't originally say screw
I thought that's thanks that's going to
be perfect for me there's something else
that they want that they're getting out
of that experience and they think it's a
good thing and they don't realize the
the badness in it and that sort of gets
ahold of them and it creeps in and the
addict after a while there's two kinds
of habits the addicts who actually
realize that they're addicts and they
hate themselves and they hate their
lives for it but they find themselves
unable to break it and then the ones who
actually still think man I'm on top of
the world this is great this is perfect
this is exactly what I want and they're
deluded about what the good is so it is
to some degree subject yeah okay the
answer that did that way I said answers
or with all that's good I didn't even
know what it was but so Socrates raises
all sorts of issues with this he says
don't we all desire good things well if
we do all desire good things that aren't
we all like virtuous automatically
that's not going to work because we want
at least a some people are virtuous and
some people are so if it's if it's
everybody gets a gold star so you tell
this there's something good that's not
going to work for a definition of virtue
and then he asks again well does having
these sorts of goods there's some goods
what are some good things like what are
the goods you're trying to achieve here
America for you yeah great yeah and
those those are actually pretty pretty
low because those are just a proxy for
something what are grades going to get
you to they care more about it Jose
State Education yeah if you want to
learn things there's a good inherent in
learning but you're not here just for
the sheer sake of learning right the
angle would be a bit down yeah and I
think that you know those those two
things with great sort of as a measure
of the middle good employment not just
good in the sense of making a ton of
money but also stuff that you'd actually
like to do the rest of your life or
there's a good portion your life and
learning some things you can take away
with you
to be embarrassed those are probably the
biggest goods grades are important as a
measure of that and then you probably
want to enjoy yourself along the way
right hope because otherwise you know
you're missing out on the student
experience hope you do want to join
yourselves we were talking about these
doctors saying because society that you
talk about a graduating and any job
either no use my goal he goes to school
like she seems an errand radical and I
some words thankfully yeah yeah there's
that there's an element of that Plato
would probably say well some societies
are better oriented towards
understanding the goods and some are
less less well oriented cuz we're going
to sort of systemic distortions but let
me let me put that up until next time
here's where he's good because we're
almost we're almost out of time having
these sorts of goods so have any good
job actually learning things long play
what is it about those that makes the
person who has them remember virtue is
about persons it's not just about what
they have or what they enjoy in order
for those goods to be good Socrates
suggests it has to be accompanied again
with justice because you can have a
great education and you can use it for
terrible things can't you and you have a
great job and you can use that great job
to wreak a great evil so it has to be
accompanied by justice again that brings
us back to this doing things well and
there's a part of virtue
you notice has been the same part of
virtue each time justice that has to
tell you about the whole of virtue so to
be virtuous is to desire good things and
to acquire them justly again circular
definition we're actually not getting
any closer to defining virtue and now we
get to the point where we meet oh and he
has his complaint a sense man Socrates
just cut everything out from under me I
have no idea what I'm talking about now
I thought anyone was talking about other
people told me I knew what I was talking
about I guess they didn't they says so
why don't you tell me now what it is and
Socrates says well it's not so simple
you see I don't know myself so now we're
going to move into the next part so
that's what rolls in close for the day
we've come quite a ways next class we'll
get into some even more interesting
issues